anchovy games the newest splatoon stage  is out the new map takes place in a  developers office complete with cubicles  and computers covered in paint its name  anchovy games is a reference to a  minigame in splatoon in game arcade  machine electric fans are found all over  the stage which can be shot with ink to  move sections of the floor entangle says  this can be used to exploit the stages  verticality and gain the high ground  over your opponent's currently intendo  has no plans to release more maps  marking anchovy games as the last stage  in the current lineup as always stay  tuned to gamespot for daily gaming news